hello Bruce Feldman good to see you here
on the Richard show Bruce Feldman from
Fox Sports and the athletic kind enough
to join us here in the Honda insider
report we'll get to Oklahoma in a second
but you spent the week with LSU prior to
the Tigers going into Atlanta and boat
racing Georgia in the SEC championship
game what did you learn from being
embedded with a tour Geron and his staff
and his team for the week there's a ton
of confidence that this team has and I
think what you see is like they were
really locked in a lot of times you see
a lot of goofing off especially as like
this is a different kind of week they
all went to the went to the site on
Thursday as opposed to go and traveling
on a Friday there was a bunch of
walkthroughs but you saw a team those
that was both really locked in but
extremely loose and I thought just
haven't been around rows around before
when there's an Ole Miss and certainly
around USC I knew they would ramp up the
energy in a big way before kickoff and
that did come but just I really think
you see a lot of people who are very
comfortable with with their roles and
you feel like I know a spread was like
six points by the time I got to the to
the dome on Saturday I was like they're
gonna beat these guys by two touchdowns
just because you just see it's like
doesn't matter what they're gonna do our
offense is gonna score 40-plus on them
and they feel like their defense is a
lot better than what people had made it
out to be because they had a really bad
performance in the second half the week
after Alabama against Ole Miss well some
of that was because some guys were hurt
their best defensive player grant Delpit
was playing with a high ankle sprain
he's healthy now I think as great as Joe
burrow has been and he's been great I
think people saw they may have the best
defensive back in the country it's not
grant out but it's Derek Stingley who's
a true freshman I mean if the Thorpe
Award was voted this week and he was a
finalist he'd probably win it I think
people saw how good he is and I think
you saw a good the receivers are how
good the running back is it's a lot more
than just than just Joel burrow but I
think you're seeing a team that keeps
going up and it's like I think that they
feel like they're destined to win a
national title and whoever they have to
play they're gonna light them up well I
want to continue on obviously
called The Insider report I want to get
a little bit more insight here and I
know the sounds may be insulting to ask
this but it's not because I just want to
know how it all works what does or girag
do I mean how what's his because
everything you said everyone's
comfortable in their roles clearly the
head man delegating and making sure
everybody is comfortable in their roles
where their roles are perfect for their
fit is exactly what a head coach is
supposed to do but walk me through what
you see from from order on there you
know if so much has been made about how
the guy used to go a hundred eighty
miles an hour and grind his team so much
has done the opposite and it's true this
is a team that they don't have staff
meetings every day that's unusual in
college football they have one on Monday
morning and that's it and then it's like
basically they're offensive guys work
with the offensive guys defensive guys
do what they're doing special teams and
everything but I think he's been really
good at not only delegating but he sets
the tone of what they expect if there's
issues they come to him with him but I
think they don't practice very long it
late in the year I mean their practice
is I want to say the ones they practice
might have been an hour 20 Oh back in
the Les Miles days would be twice that
long in November so I think he's become
really smart about understanding the
science about athletes and how they
respond to it and also think what he's
being really good at I think he has a
real good feel for the team and
everything is kind of focused in on okay
what are we gonna do here are we gonna
be really good with the details and so I
remember back in this in the spring when
I was there certain kind of drills that
they would set up where he would he'll
sit in there with his defensive line
staff and he'll be the they'll watch
practice and then he can report back to
the offensive line guys cuz he knows at
the end of the day as great as Joe
burrow and those receivers are it's a
game in the trenches and so a lot of the
specific stuff that he is really kind of
drilling down on the technique stuff and
then he'll get back to the individual
coaches about hey these are the things
we need to work on with that particular
guy so I think he just has a really
great feel for the pulse of each player
and he and where they're at
which I think gets lost so much in
college football you think about who's
really great with the X's and O's
who's really good as a scheme or as a
you know as a play caller I think what's
really proven to be really impressive
about him is he just has a feel for
where the team is and the pulse of the
team you know on a day-to-day sense and
then so then how did us see you
mentioned his days of us see how they
miss on him I mean was he just not the
same guy is he's just not an LA guy cuz
he does sound like he's he's he's
straight from the waterboy we yeah
effort for LSU I mean I'm serious I
think what you have is a guy who just
continued to evolve for he made a huge
jump from when he was at Ole Miss to USC
I think he's made a significant jump
after that but I really think it's a USC
issue you have a lot of people at USC
especially back in that Pat Haden regime
who couldn't get past what Eddowes Ron
sounded like they didn't listen to the
players they didn't listen to the staff
I think at the end of the day you had
guys who are editor on it's not a
country-club guy I think he can relate
to just about anybody you see I mean the
governor of Louisiana was waiting
outside the locker I mean you can like
he's a very street-smart and I think
that's one of things that made him a
really good recruiter is I think he can
read people very well I don't think Pat
Haden who was the decision-maker at the
time that's just not the kind of guy he
he wanted and I just don't think he
could get past it and it's not you know
it's interesting was that I think there
were five or six guys who were old USC
guys who are on that staff and I spent a
bunch of time around Marcus Allen who
was a USC great I was you're on and he
became close he spoke to the team last
week against I get before a Texas A&M
game Marcus was there on the sidelines
John Robinson legendary coach who is a
USC is now part of their program and I
think you see so many guys who
understand what Oh Ron is way better
than Pat Haden ever did and that's why
USC is where USC is right now and LSU is
the number one seed going in the play
well let's put a pin in the USC part of
the conversation is we just are with
Honda inside a hunter insider reporter
if you will if you don't mind me calling
you that from the athletic and Fox
Sports Bruce Feldman here on the Rich
Eisen show let's put a pin on the USC
and the other coaching stuff for a
second
what is it like being inside the meeting
room with Joe burrow and and Joe Brady
you want to talk about a great thing
that
did he goes and he's like let's take
this young guy who's been around Sean
Payton let's bring him here to be a
passing game coordinator for for us
what's it like being in that meeting
because because Joe burrows just to
finish the sentence I'm sitting there
watching part of the SEC championship
game on the big screen during the NFL
gameday morning meeting Kurt Warner
hall-of-famer
turns to the screen he goes man where
did Jill borrow where did this Jill
borrow come from as we're watching him
just pinpoint accurate throw through
windows that are just inches wide or
tall so what's it like being in that
room yeah a coach's kid who's incredibly
smart way more athletic than people give
him credit for I think we see elements
of that but if you watch it there's
stuff in the design run game that they
do and I think what you mentioned Joe
Brady and that's easy to confuse they're
actually not that much different in age
huh Joe Brady was a guy who had who had
played at William and Mary but he had G
aid at Penn State under James Franklin
learned Joel Moorhead's run game and
then took elements of that they have
elements of the Chargers run game
because James Craig was the offensive
line coach had been with them been with
the Broncos so that's kind of the run
game and then it's a lot of saints
passing concepts that Joe Brady bought
brought with him and I mean Joe Brady is
a brilliant young guy when you see him
before there's it's kind of an
interesting mix of what you're seeing
because he's very soft-spoken yet he's
you know when the team's meet at team
meals he's eating with the receivers
most of the coaches he with the coat of
their coaches Joe Brady eats with the
receivers that's what he that's the
position he coaches and he comes out in
the in sharp light silver suit with the
light purple tie yet he's got on the
fancy Air Jordans he's got the
headphones
I think players see him as one of them
so he doesn't talk to borrow is what
you're saying he he does but Steve
Stevens mayor who's the author right so
Joe Brady calls some of the plays with
red zone and third downs and Stevens
Mary handles the rest of it and I think
it's worked out really well because
Ensminger who's been an offensive
coordinator for a long time former LSU
quarterback he's in his early 60s he has
everybody's respect there and I think
the back and forth between the two is
impressive because I think you
the game planning but when it comes to
coaching the position it's really on
ends being on that side but I think in
terms of what the play calls what what
what young Joe versus an almost not so
young Joe want I think a lot of that
dialogue happens over the phone you know
it when the defense is on the field but
there's there were so many walkthroughs
where you could see what do you expect
and I think we're where Joe Brady is
really impressive especially is with his
rapport with the receivers and I think
so when you look at a guy who goes from
58 or 59 percent to 79% this isn't just
a bubble screen often he's just crazy
taking shots I think it's really how
much what Joe Brady's done with the
whole passing game and really the
receivers have gotten so much better and
I think what Joe borough has done is the
timing he has developed with all those
kids and a lot of them are a little
younger than him but taking them out
yeah you know it's a hundred degrees and
a hundred percent humidity in Baton
Rouge in the summer and I think where
you see plays that take off those are
things that they have so many different
options within a play and I think you
have such a savvy triggerman that's
making it work I think that's why this
offense and they also have a great
running back and Clyde Edwards who layer
who is really good and out of him man
yeah he's he's really special because he
is so good in the pass game and I think
you have a lot of kids right now who are
really smart yeah brandy Moss has son
Thaddeus who's not 65 but he's he's
really emerged as a weapon so you have
three dynamic receivers kind of a tight
end even though they split him out a lot
and a running back so you're looking at
five wide a lot of times and these SEC
defenses have no clue how to deal with
it because he operates it so well a few
more minutes left with Bruce Feldman
here in the Honda inside a report I
guess having spent the first eight some
odd minutes of this Honda inside a
report talking about LS you were making
DuBose when he's point here that they
are the defending champs they haven't
lost a game they are third overall so
what does the college football playoff
committee saying to Dabo Swinney
that he's obviously balling up and he's
using it about nobody believes in this
but what is the message here do you
think you play in a league that was
really down this year I don't think was
no fault of their own they played two
SEC teams in their non-conference
I think credit to Clemson for scheduling
them it's not their fault yes the ACC is
way down this year the ACC you know
Florida State had a coaching change
Miami had a coaching change last year
Virginia Tech was inconsistent III think
you look at some of these other teams
Virginia had a nice year but there was
nobody really that was a legitimate top
15 team or even close to that around
them and so if you want to ding Clemson
for anything you almost lost to it to a
North Carolina team that was barely bowl
eligible but after that I mean they they
were crushing everybody else so I think
Clemson nose and Dabo can say hey you
know say what he's gonna say I mean at
the end of the day if they handle their
business against Ohio State it doesn't
matter where you are 1 2 or 3 or 4 I
think they are they're as dangerous a
team as there is because they have so
much firepower and Trevor Lawrence has
done it on a big stage these other guys
have done it they haven't done it on the
ground stage and he did it against
Alabama where to me you know it's almost
like you know Mike Tyson wasn't beaten
it was beaten more than once
but it was when Buster Douglas knocked
him out that wasn't whoa and that's what
it felt like with Clemson because they
just blew them off the field weren't
even close so I think everybody has like
Dabo but I think everybody has if you if
you don't respect Clemson you're kidding
yourself I mean we'll see what happens
against Ohio State I think that's gonna
be a great matchup this will be as good
a semi-final game as I think we've had
in the playoff year and what are the
chances that LSU makes it Alabama
doesn't but it's Jalen Hertz that beats
them anyway how remarkable would that be
that Jalen Hertz he's against I know
that's what I mean and and and if again
I I know that the cop there in the in
the committee they're not supposed to
match teams up with storylines and
levels of interest but to me the fact
that Alabama's former quarterback who
doesn't get a shot in Alabama anymore
because of 2a goes to Oklahoma and is
the one that shows up and takes on LSU
in the first round I think that is just
a chef's kiss delicious meal that's
possible
I guess nobody probably appreciates that
more than the quarterback in Norman
Oklahoma I mean I we did for his games
this year at Fox and I remember talking
to him before him before they played
Iowa State late in the year and at one
point he said to me this is a couple
days before the game he was talking
about just being new whereas Tyler
Murray and Baker who both obviously want
Huysmans they'd been there three years
and had a chance to get to know
everybody he didn't and he talked about
changing the culture there and I said
well they just two guys just won the
Heisman it's not like he just took over
Kansas football and he goes listen I've
been to three national titles in a row
so and his words just hung there and so
he has a really high standard he has he
is right near right below the surface
with him there's not lacking for
confidence and we'll see their defense
got better as the year went on it is
definitely not what the other three
teams have but they do have talking out
of fell Scouts Kenneth Murray he will be
a first-round pick he's in the middle of
their defense right Neville Gallimore is
a big-time guy it's those other guys in
the secondary the secondary is is a big
concern they do not have the kind of
personnel that you want to see from a
playoff team in the secondary at least
and that's what Joe burrow is gonna be
attacking
so if Oklahoma's gonna win that game it
may have to be a 55:51 kind of game and
that Georgia can't beat LSU can't get
into the college football playoff
because that but just in fields does and
he has the opportunity to knock off
clemson or maybe then also knock off LSU
I mean that is pretty another delicious
sort of yeah there's a lot of vengeance
I'm seeing coming from your desk right
yeah I'm trying to just they're good
subplots no doubt and and I think what
you have there to also by the way our
friend Trent Dilfer must have been like
three years ago I remember going to his
elite 11 right and the two most talented
quarterbacks and I think Trent probably
has said this to you before the two most
talented quarterbacks
I think he's ever had come through there
are the guys were matching up in that
bowl game Trevor Lawrence Justin fields
both Georgia guys by the way both from
right to the state they're not from far
away both big really athletic kids with
terrific arms you can I mean try and
I'll probably tell you I think he's I
think he thought Justin
even more talented than Trevor at least
back then I don't know where people view
it now but that shows you you know the
the the talent we have with these
trigger with these quarterbacks in this
in this Final Four are you surprised
that the new athletic director and USC
Mike bone said to clay Helton and stick
around I was probably about ten days
before it came to that because I started
calling we did a big story about it on
the athletic how mike bone the ad and
the new president Carol folt were
leaning in that direction that they were
comfortable with clay Helton and look
it's in in his defense clay Helton did a
pretty good job with a team that ended
eight and four they lost their starting
quarterback JT Daniels at the beginning
of the year and the team never quit on
him now it wasn't a great year but it
definitely wasn't a bad year especially
given they're playing with a true
freshman quarterback I think when a lot
of people will look at this and say oh
well clay Helton is and they'll point to
like a slightly better than 500 record
when they don't have Sam Darnell but
that's not really fair because he was
the one who found Sam Darnell he was
only develop Sam Donald now he has
another three-star guy who's much better
than a three-star guy in Keaton slovis
at quarterback and I think when the USC
brass really looked at it they said okay
we have come out especially it's Carol
Fulton who president remember us he is
at all sorts of scandal we both live out
here on the west coast it's beyond just
the football program right and so I
think they were gonna be very careful
with who she wanted to be as the face of
the unit of the university especially at
this time now a year from now who knows
what its gonna look like from my
reporting also heard that clay Hilton's
buyout along with the staff is much more
than it's been reported to be that's
what somebody had told me like I said
about two weeks ago and so you started
to kind of read the tea leaves it was
heading in that direction I know a lot
of the fans don't like that and they're
gonna open up against Alabama but if
Alabama blows them off the field then I
think you're gonna get a lot of a lot of
people going right he's been on the hot
seat now for three years that's hard for
recruiting I mean they don't have a big
class to sign any because I don't have a
lot of scholarship space the way it's
worked out but this recruiting class is
gonna be one of the lowest ranks
probably they've ever had
but at the same time the leadership
feels comfortable with clay Helton and
they're gonna move forward whether the
fans like it or not okay I got three
minutes left so let's quick hitter here
was Bob Stoops close to Florida State or
a USC at all or no no no Bob Stoops
likes where like his situation I don't
think he was gonna jump in the middle
especially Florida State has all kinds
of administrative issues and that's not
something he would want to park why did
Florida state do what it did a
microphone was kind of to me the default
leader in the clubhouse he's a he done a
really good job at Memphis a lot of
people really like him as an offensive
coach I think he's probably about as
good as they could have hoped to have
gotten at this point especially
considering they're not sure who the ad
or the president gonna be in the next
couple years okay and the odds are that
Lincoln Riley's next game in Dallas will
be for the Cowboys I don't like those
odds
I just don't think Lincoln will
ultimately leave what he's got right now
wouldn't shock me if he left but I think
he knows I work for the best ad in
college sports and Joe Castiglione I've
got I've got the staff I wanted to build
around we've gotten better on defense
were recruiting well I got a young
family the NFL will be there five years
from now if I really want to do it so
Urban Meyer there I mean that's the
that's the conversation right now I
don't know our friend Daniel Jeremiah
made a prediction to me a week or two
ago saying he thinks that it will be Dan
Mullen who's an Urban Meyer protege who
by the way coached and developed at
Prescott and you know what in terms of
Meza next Dallas Cowboys head that's
what DJ said I had not heard that from
anybody unlike anybody else but he kind
of put about you know two plus two plus
two and got there and the part that is
interesting is remember the Jimmy Jerry
stuff blew up because of Jerry's ego and
who he wants to be in place there Dan
Mullins you know it's not to just merge
him but Urban Meyer is a big name you
bring him in there I don't know if I
don't know I don't I don't know if urban
wants to jump back in the middle of the
of the coaching chaos either maybe maybe
be tempted by the you know how do you
not listen to the Dallas Cowboys though
right last minute I have for you here
the miles per hour on the campus in
Oxford Mississippi is 10 miles an hour
right it is 18 18 miles an hour when I
give an Eli that
for our cheer arches so does that mean
because again they don't do anything
without Archie Manning I mean having
some say is there an Archie was there an
Archie Manning Lane Kiffin conversation
that actually did happen you know and is
there a transcript of it yeah it's gonna
be you know what this is great for us in
the media I think it's good for the for
the for the local scene and Oxford I'm
not sure it's really good for the SEC
Commissioner cuz Lane will stir stuff up
so better or worse if Archie Manning and
Lane Kiffin were put together in a room
I need I need the transcript I need the
conversation it's gotta happen to have
happen got to have to be existing that
would be amazing
thank you for being here sir I really
appreciate it always a pleasure you got
it that's Bruce Delvin Breaux more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 under red TV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app